good morning believe nation today's
message is evolved over to you Howard
Stern the person who doesn't grow or
change is dull and remains dull and will
never ever succeed you constantly have
to evolve and change and I don't mean
just from like whether or not you played
the dating game on the air I mean your
your whole lifestyle your opinions your
view of the world has to evolve or else
it's it's a dead issue you're done so we
think i do1 said you've always got to be
making yourself better than day before
but one thing I like that is even if you
don't achieve on the phone about it
yesterday is to not give up because it's
eventually gonna happen if we keep
trying I think too many people lock
themselves in a box and you do the same
thing over and over and over in the same
routine and as such as you get older you
just you wake up you go to work come
home when it's the same thing over and
over and over again and life starts to
get really boring and I think you need
to shake it up you need to do things a
little bit different I think even
looking at you yeah so his story he came
by two weeks ago two weeks ago yeah two
weeks ago as the first time just walking
by the studio we're in a mall and he's
like oh I know you and I've seen your
YouTube channel and said hey why don't
you come by next week and I'll put you
on the channel and Alex who you guys all
know said he's not going to come back is
not going to come back said now he's
gonna come back for sure he's gonna come
back so he ended up coming back the next
week but it came back a little bit too
late because I didn't give him the time
window and so it was Miss I said you
know what come back next week which is
now this week and he's here and that was
doing the videos and so he's of all when
I was is he gets to be on this channel
he gets to grow he's learning how to do
better speaking and so it's it's those
little things that test your comfort
zone
should be the best version of yourself
that I think when you have that voice
inside your head that's like pushing you
away from it to say though that's too
scary or I can't do it or I'm going to
make a mistake i'm going to make a fool
of myself when you're scared you'll hold
yourself back from doing what you really
should go up to do so I mean that boys
comes up you got to go and take action
and continue to evolve yeah and one more
thing is that you only live once and I
think it's much better to live with
failure then live with regret I love it
that's a good one yes so the question
today today is you would like to know on
what you're evolving in your life right
now it doesn't have to be business
related or anything it could be anything
but we would like to know what are your
future plans on evolving on something
leave in the comments below will join a
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shut up and press ok
TV